i'm alone in this bathroom now and i'm
about to commence
the
daying i don't know anything about
bidets really i've never
had a need or a want to use one the
dingleberry issue is a common one for
men with uh sort of my
uh
follicle situation i'm a little bit
scared i've never had anything in that
area before going up in that area before
so the butthole is just like an untapped
place for me i've seen bidets before
i've never seen one with so many buttons
there's a wash on button that is very
clearly water going up into a butt the
bidet on button makes no sense it's like
a face which is freakish i do really
like this heated seat function i think
this is just needs to be like mandatory
in all toilets you know full disclosure
i left one in the chamber this morning
so i could get the full effect here and
sort of see what's uh happening so i'm
just gonna go all in and press the day
this is terrifying
oh gosh oh wow oh oh jesus what's going
on
oh my god what is this
oh god oh that feels nice
oh my god that's fantastic it's better
if you relax
wow if you angle it it can just get like
like right now torpedo just like
like right in there
[Music]
all right getting a little bit more used
to this it's a weird sensation having
water being sprayed at your butt like
this i don't know what to compare this
to i've never had this feeling before
it's like a massage for your anus but
it's wet
this is fantastic it's kind of just
making my butt nub i feel like because
i've been doing this for a while my butt
feels like it's starting to get a little
pruney the test
yeah smooth i would say i did not enjoy
what just happened to me my butt feels
really clean right now
like i didn't know it could be this
clean i would never use one of these
ever again um that was lovely i really
enjoyed it i almost kind of feel like i
just peed my pants so now i'm confused
about what happens because i'm very wet
down there
i feel like no matter what i still need
to use toilet paper to at least dry off
it's not like you just washed your hands
and you can like you know blot your
hands on your pants if it had like a
little mini blow dryer in there that
would like you know
dry you out
this would be super choice yeah i mean
it's like it's like a flu shot you know
you don't want it but once you have it
you're like okay that's i'm glad i'm
glad i did that
oh jesus
no no no oh
whoa what